[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday September 2nd
I'm Cindy Yu The Spectators broadcast
editor
we've got a great show for you this week
The Spectators chairman engineer will be
returning to the show to tell us about
the bargain that the Scottish greens
after struck with Nicholas sturgeon in
return for a seat at the table of
government
we'll also be debating with Animal
Welfare campaigner Dominic Dyer you
might have seen him advocating for the
safe evacuation of Penn farthing's dogs
and cats on whether human lives are
worth more than animal lives
and it's boarding school to blame for
lackluster British politicians Richard
beard thinks so he is himself a product
of the institution and he joins the show
to talk about his new book on the matter
sad little men
before we get going if you enjoy what we
do on spectator TV then subscribe to our
YouTube channel for free click the
button at the bottom of this video and
then tap the Bell icon to make sure you
never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the selectator
magazine too we're giving spectator TV
viewers an exclusive offer you can get
10 weeks of The Spectator for just 10
pounds and a free bottle of pins when
you subscribe at spectator.co.uk forward
slash TV offer it's a fantastic offer
and we're only running it while stocks
last so hurry
now before I'm joined by Andrew Neil
let's hear from our home team of
excellent journalists James Forsyth
Katie bores and Kate Andrews on the
political situation this week
James and Katie welcome to spectator TV
now James to start with you Dominic
Robertson Doha as we film what's his
mission there
his mission there is essentially it's
part of a regional tour to start working
on trying to get out those Afghans who
worked or helped with the British
Mission and are still in Afghanistan it
is a sentence attempt to try and secure
a safe passage for them out of the
country I think one thing that there is
concern about in both London and
Washington is you know what reprisals
might there be against those who worked
with NATO forces and you know
the moral responsibility that is owed to
those people and there are still a large
number of those people who have been
left behind in Afghanistan which is
obviously now under Taliban control
thinking though that the Taliban was
operating out of Doha before its a
Resurgence in Afghanistan so with the
qataris actually help the British side
here
yeah I mean the idea is that the qataris
are the people who have influence on the
Taliban you know if you want to if you
want to try and persuade the Taliban to
do something the idea goes that they're
the people who can help you with that
they've hosted since 2013 the taliban's
political office and one of the aims is
to try and use them to put pressure on
the Taliban to keep Kabul International
Airport open obviously there is some
difficulty here because uh other
countries will be reluctant to Grant
overflight rights to a plane setting off
from Afghanistan unless they have some
assurances on the security on the ground
so there is talk of whether the Turks or
the qataris could provide the airport
security the Taliban are obviously
sensitive to the idea of you know of
kind of foreign troops on their soil
running the airport so I think it's
trying to negotiate all of these things
and then I think the other question is
can you persuade uh countries in the
neighborhood that are obviously very
worried about a huge influence of
refugees from Afghanistan can you
persuade them to accept those people who
are going to end up being granted asylum
in in Western countries
Katie you've got a very interesting
interview in this week's spectator with
Ben Wallace the defense secretary and
it's clear that there's no love lost
between him and Dominic Robb at the
moment isn't it I mean how are relations
between the two men
so you have a situation where they're
not directly attacking one another but
when you look at the various things
they're saying and their version of
events they uh so they do not come
together in a harmonious fashion so you
have Dominic RAV trying to explain the
chaotic scenes in Kabul how the UK was
caught on the hop by blaming Military
Intelligence saying the intelligence
failed and then you have Ben Wallace the
defense secretary in the interview with
me in The Spectator saying that fields
of intelligence aren't what went wrong
because there isn't really such a thing
as a failure of intelligence when it
comes in this context when it comes to
the end of a regime when it comes to a
crisis like this what you get is a you
know there are limits of intelligence
and it did feel to me as though that was
a rebuke to this idea that though this
was the thing that went wrong and
nothing else can be read he also had Ben
Wallace talking about the fact that he
was warning in July that things had to
move faster because the game was up now
if you look at Dominic rav's timetable
he was saying in a select committee
appearance ultimately no one could have
known this and I think what's tricky for
robbers is not just what Ben Wallace is
saying you also have an internal foreign
office memo which suggested that in July
they were also warned that the situation
could escalate in Afghanistan very
quickly and now Dominic Robb's response
as well you hear lots of things and
there's some of this advice you get
different advice but I think it's just
adding up to this pitch of it it just
does not feel so credible that Dominic
Ralph was completely taken by surprise
and others by how quickly things moved
and especially when you considered his
holiday answer questions to which he
refused to answer at the Foreign Affairs
select committee as well because he may
well have been already on holiday at
this point um Katie on on on the
relationship between the two men and
their prospects in cabinets there have
been briefings around Westminster that
only one of them can stay in a future
reshuffle it's Ben Wallace in a better
stead with a parliamentary party than
Dominic Robb at the moment
certainly in the Parliamentary party I
would say Ben Wallace is one of the few
figures in government who stock and
raise and was risen
um through the crisis I think his
engagement with MPS and uh the way that
mod has worked on this has been
something which you you see public
praise for so uh I think figures such as
Johnny Mercer you know former Defense
Minister back bench has been quite
critical the government have found
praise for Ben Wallace I think when it
comes to Cabinet
um there's obviously been a pylon
against Dominic rub it's worth
remembering that Boris Johnson doesn't
really play by conventional wisdom when
it comes to moving people from his
cabinet and sackings really happen if
ever resignations uh you know is not
something that he really prompts people
to do and therefore I think it is quite
hard to predict what will happen to
Dominic Robin in any reshuffle I think
that one of the things I'm now hearing
though is the fact that we are seeing
this blame game play out in public
between the home office the mod and the
foreign office it it looks dysfunctional
and I think that it's actually now
reflecting on Boris Johnson the fact
that you have a situation where he is
overseeing a government where there
isn't a clear narrative and people seem
to be letting almost their dirty laundry
player in public and James on that Ben
Wallace interview what did you think of
his point that uh it was obvious that
the UK is not a superpower but also that
the US might not even be a superpower
just the just the global power just the
strong power given what's happening in
Afghanistan
yeah I think it's interesting there's
some pointy comments towards the end of
interview and he talks Joe Biden kept
saying that he wants to end the forever
war in Afghanistan
and Ben Wallace is essentially arguing
that standing up for your for your
values is a forever commitment
and I think that that I think it's very
hard not to read that as a as a dig at
the Biden decision to pull out I think
it's been quite clear for some time that
the view in the ministry of defense is
look you know from about 2013 2014
onwards the NATO had found a way of
staying in Afghanistan with a relatively
light footprint uh the Afghan Army did
the fighting but there are a few
thousand uh us and NATO forces there and
crucially air support being provided to
the Afghan Army and I think it is no
secret that that is what the UK would
have liked to see continue I think one
of the interesting things here is that
it's quite clear that if you read Joe
Biden's speech on Tuesday night
justifying the withdrawal that you know
his essential argument is you know the
US is now involved in a great power
competition with China and to a lesser
extent Russia and he wishes to kind of
get out of all of these uh Post 9 11
entanglements that he regards i i as
kind of Superfluous about struggle and
that you know the US is essentially
planning to return to that pre-9 11
approach of what you know over the
horizon capabilities essentially what
that means is you know you hear about a
terrorist training camp somewhere you
fire a bunch of cruise missiles into it
you know George Bush
famously said after 9 11 you know he
wasn't going to do that anymore because
he didn't think it was effective you
were sending in a two billion uh sorry a
two million dollar missile to hit an
empty ten dollar tent and a camel in the
butt uh but I think the us is going back
to that strategy when it comes to uh
these kind of terrorist facilities and
Katie let's talk a little bit about
what's happening back at home as well
because we're counting down the stage to
the return to school
um cases have been falling throughout
the summer but is there nervousness that
when school returns it would change
yes because if you look at Scotland
where cases are rocking
um that is being attributed to people's
uh going back to the classroom in part
and I think therefore ministers are
worried and now you're seeing it move
into debate about child vaccination and
previously the government was fairly
divided you didn't get the sense there
was a strong uh overwhelming viewing
cabinet that they're a pro-child
vaccination for the over 12s but I think
that started to shift so you're hearing
Gavin Williamson among others uh almost
putting pressure on the body the medical
body that recommends this to come up
with a decision and I think there is a
frustration I'm picking up from
ministers that they cannot progress in
this when lots of countries are far
ahead now if the UK does decide to go
ahead for child vaccination which seems
to be what the government is leaning
towards if they get to that point I
think it will be not without controversy
but I think that is now the clear
direction of travel in terms of what
Boris Johnson would like to see as one
way of tackling and what they expect to
be jump in cases when people return and
James let's talk about that vaccination
point because the government is trying
to pressurize the jcvi in order to to
allow booster shots but they're not
getting very much they're not getting
anywhere are they yeah I mean it's worth
thinking back to the to the beginning of
the vaccination program you know the UK
was the first country to to give someone
a covered vaccine outside of a clinical
trial and ministers then we're full of
praise for the mnhra and the jcbi but
there is now a clear tension between
ministers and the jcbi because ministers
want to get going for booster campaign
but jcbi have so far only approved to
boost the shot for those people who've
um suppressed immune systems I think
it's also quite clear as Casey was
saying that you know um and as I quote
someone involved in the planning to
return to schools the magazine this week
saying you know they thought that
ministers thought they would be further
down the age cohorts by now before the
return to school I mean they are looking
quite enviously at those countries that
have for quite some time been
vaccinating everyone at over 12.
um and I've thought I think this is this
is going to become attention because you
know as Casey says you know there's a
Scottish example does suggest that you
will see a spike in cases you know it's
worth remembering that with the return
of Education this month you know schools
colleges and universities that's about
13 million people changing their daily
routine it would be very surprising in
fact didn't have an effect on the
covered case numbers and James as you
write in your political column for this
week's spectator the government seems to
be in a bit of a paradox where they
should be doing well they seem to be
doing well but they don't feel like
they're doing well can you explain
what's going on there
yeah I think it's a very odd thing you
know the Tories have been in government
for 11 years you know now after a new
labor of being in government for 11
years they were about 19 points behind
the Tories and the polls
um after the Tories have been in power
for 11 years in 1990 that following that
those victories in 79 83 and 87 they
were regularly behind by double digits
yet the toys are consistently
um still ahead in the polls 11 years
after first taking office you know you
combine that with Kia stormers ratings
here you go poll out this week had his
approval rating at -39
and you'd think that the Tories would be
in Fairly triumphalous mood but they're
not and I think when Tory MPS return uh
to the comments next week they will do
so in a strikingly subdued mood
um I was talking to one cabinet minister
this week
and they were saying you know they
always fought but MP's returning to
Westminster you know the end of these
covert restrictions in Parliament packed
benches in the Commons would be a big
boost uh to party morale and to the
government because you know you'd have
that numerical advantage in in the
chamber again and they said that they're
now they're now not so sure because they
think the mood is is is sufficiently
glum that um that you're not going to
get that boost out of it
James and Katie thanks very much for
joining spectator TV now let's take a
closer look at those covert numbers with
Kate Andrews our economics editor who
puts together the spectator's daily
lunchtime briefing which is the only
newsletter you need for covert news from
the UK and around the world Kate over to
you
thanks Cindy on this first graph you're
looking at the seven day average for
covert infections in England which as
you can see have been slightly on the
decline for about a week now notably
below the peak of the reopening wave
over the summer but the virus is still
circulating as we would expect given how
many of the restrictions have now been
lifted this light dip is interesting in
the context of cases in Scotland whereas
you can see here the virus is still on
the rise it's been thought at moments
over the summer that England was
following Scotland's trajectory but
they're moving in different directions
now there are of course key differences
Scottish schools have been back for
several weeks and this increase May well
be a result of schools returning when
English schools are back in full force
it's expected that this could lead to an
increase even a spike in the number of
cases so England may be following in
Scotland's Footsteps in the coming weeks
we wait and see of course in both
England and Scotland The crucial metrics
remain hospitalization and death in
England hospitalizations remain roughly
80 percent below their Peak and when we
look at coveted deaths it's roughly 92
to 93 percent below the peak so that's
on the face of it good news a lot of
eyes now are turning away from the UK
and towards Israel which appears to be
undergoing a fourth wave possibly a bad
sign for the UK's prospects of handling
the virus in the months ahead again
though context is key perhaps the
biggest point to make here is that
Israel has just been flooded with the
Delta variant which it's experiencing
now something that the UK experienced
earlier this summer the UK also decided
to leave a longer gap between the first
and second vaccines which may create
stronger immunity against the virus but
evidence is increasing in both the UK
and Israel that immunity built up from
vaccines starts to wane not disappear
but Wayne around four to six months
post-jab The crucial point is that we're
talking about infection when it comes to
severe illness and preventing against it
so far vaccines continue to hold up well
still this has strengthened the case for
booster shots this last graph here shows
that cases of severe coveted illness
were on track to double every two weeks
in Israel until the booster program
kicked in now it's early days and there
could be other explanations for this so
let's not get too excited but no doubt a
major topic this Autumn will be those
booster jobs here in the UK and to what
extent they're necessary to increase
protection especially for the vulnerable
and elderly back to you Cindy
Kate Andrews thank you for that now if
you enjoyed Kate's insights and the
numbers that The Spectator are putting
together on Covert do check out our
covert data Hub at spectata.co.uk
forward slash data on there you'll find
the latest information on National
numbers the vaccine tracker and much
more or you can subscribe to Kate's
daily newsletter to get the highlights
in your inbox
spectator.co.uk forward slash lunchtime
Dash briefing next this week I'm
delighted to Welcome Back The Spectators
chairman Angel he's been closely
following The Pact that the Scottish
greens have signed up with the SMP or
another Ploy for Independence but is it
a good deal for the s p or the greens or
Scotland
Andrew welcome back to spectator TV good
to be back and great to see you
spectator TV doing so well this is very
weird because we're reversing positions
here but tell us about tell us about
what's going on with the green party and
the s p north of the Border because have
they struck some kind of foul Stone
bargain well they certainly struck some
kind of deal it's not a full-blooded
coalition
uh but it's a semi-coalition and the
greens get uh two positions in
government now two in a Nicola
sturgeon's government two positions
especially created for them I mean one
will be a minister for zero carbon
buildings active travel which I think
means walking uh and tenants rights and
they're going to go for rent controls
the other will be the minister for green
skills the circular economy I'm not
quite sure what that is and biodiversity
I mean this is how you pick ministerial
jobs by just going into a dictionary and
picking out words and actually the
titles and they've been entirely
creating for these two they've never
been in government before
um
I think it's it's all Optics it's a bit
performative here from Nicholas
surgeon's point of view I think that um
she failed in the May Scottish
Parliament elections she did incredibly
well but she failed to get an overall
majority uh but she now brings the seven
green votes in she can claim that she
has a quote super majority in Parliament
for a second Independence referendum
which she hopes she will win now there's
a bit of maneuvering here because the
fact is that Nicholas dungeon could
almost count on the votes of the greens
for a second referendum anyway and I
think it's simply she's got very little
red meat at the moment to give her own
supporters and this is at least
something come the SNP conference this
month that she can throw at them to say
you know I've now built in guaranteed a
super majority for a second referendum
the greens get their feet in government
these two characters get another thirty
thousand pounds a year each of their
wonderful roles and zero carbon
buildings and circular economy and
um and I think that's probably the
second reason why there's something in
it I mean there's a lot of downsides
which we can come on to I think the
second performative or Optical reason
for Nicholas sturgeon is that cop 26 the
great big climate Jamboree coming up in
Glasgow in November I mean that's a
Boris Johnson show uh I'm Nicola
sturgeon uh as the minister of only a
default Parliament has felt a bit left
out she'll now be able to mingle with
the Great and the good saying I'm now in
Coalition with the greens the greens are
part of my government that is how much
I'm I'm a Greenie myself and I think
that will help us strut the
international Sage a bit well I did
think it was funny though that Greta
thundberg the sort of Joan of Arc
character for the green movement you
know she said that Scotland is not a
world leader on climate change that
can't have been convenient for Nicholas
surgeon it wasn't convenient for Nicola
sturgeon and it shows how the cybernaths
these uh terribly Pleasant people on
Twitter and so on uh will turn on his
fixmen's Burma who who said something
which actually isn't that controversial
you know Scotland isn't really a world
leader and this is pretty good at
Renewables but on all sorts of other
things it's still way behind she says
Scotland isn't a world leader and
suddenly this International icon This
Global icon is being duffed over as if
she was in sakiol Street on a Saturday
night
um there's the pubs closed and fighting
broke out
um and the terrible things being said
about it so it shows that you you can
get their support but the moment you say
something they don't like they're down
on you like a ton of bricks they're not
either this will come as a surprise to
you they're not the nicest people
um and Andrew when it comes to the
greens you've written that they make the
green South of the Border sound sensible
by comparison now you've talked a little
bit about the circular economy and other
things but what do they stand for and
how much more radical are they
well put it this way the the English
greens are a lot more radical than the
German greens uh who are very grown up
greens and they've been in government
before and they could well be in
government in Germany again after the
elections later this month so the
English greens are not as grown up as
the German greetings who are actually
now a moderate center-left a green party
and the Scottish greens are nowhere near
as moderate as the English greens
they're pretty much outliers in the
green spectrum and they are they want to
abolish the royal family you know lots
of people want to do that that's not
particularly radical but they want to
take confiscate all their lands as well
they want a wealth tax and if the
Scottish
um Parliament doesn't have power for a
wealth tax which it probably doesn't at
the moment they say that should be done
by local authorities well anybody who
knows local authorities in Scotland
giving them a wealth tax we put the fear
of death into you there they are
anti-car they are anti above all
anti-economic growth they want rent
controls and the one thing that you know
economists really agree about anything
but the one thing that economists are on
the left and the right agree about is
how terrible rent controls are uh yeah
that isn't just a Milton Friedman or the
Adam Smith Institute uh Paul Krugman the
leveling Economist who writes for the
New York Times Nobel Prize winner he
said that rent controls are a disaster
everywhere they've been introduced
Berlin Stockholm uh even at some extent
in New York and days gone by they lead
to terrible shortages of rental uh
property but that's what they want now
Nicholas sturgeon is a canny politician
and she has not given them their wish
list at all and indeed she has basically
ring fenced the economy from this
anti-economic growth uh faction and
she's not agreed that if you do more
than one return flight a year you pay an
escalating rate of tax for every other
flight she's not stupid she's not going
to go down that road uh either the Scots
like there's summer holidays in the sun
um but it is a problem for her because
she has aligned herself in terms of
public perception perception with a
clear anti-growth anti-capitalist
anti-market Economy Party I mean Mr
Harvey the co-head of the greens has
said that he wants capitalism must end
he said not that long ago how he intends
to do that we don't know and I think
it's a problem for Nicholas sturgeon as
far as business is concerned and foreign
investment which Scotland needs a lot of
or even investment from England as well
because Nicholas Sturgill was already
seen as not as business friendly as Alex
salmon her predecessor Alex was uh was
seen as being yes a Social Democrat but
when it came to business in the economy
had been a former Economist at the Royal
Bank of Scotland uh he knew what he was
talking about he was actually in favor
of very low rates of cooperation tax uh
which was attractive to business
Nicholas sturgeon jumped that she's just
I mean I remember interviewing
Alexander's ones up in uh just outside
Aberdeen in a hotel that was owned by
one of his big supporters this was a
businessman and he he just said Alex
Simon he's going to be great for
business uh you know he really
understands how business operates no
one's saying that about Nicholas dungeon
and now she's in bed with the greens who
are clearly an anti-business policy
anti-investment in roads anti-upgrading
roads anti-economic uh Growth Oil and
Gas a huge issue still in Scotland
hundred thousand well-paid jobs
depending on it they are against further
development of oil and gas the greens
have said they are responsible for these
significant can change of Direction in
the Scottish government when it comes to
oil and gas so when you add all that up
it it
reduces Scotland's
attractiveness as a place to do business
and a place in which you might consider
investing and
you mentioned Nicholas sturgeon hasn't
given them their
medical demands or many demands at all
and it almost seems like a law of nature
for coalitions that a smaller party gets
eaten up
yes it does as uh Nick clack will tell
you
after his experience with David Cameron
and Josh Osborne I mean I think it does
have dangers for the greens and we did
we've already seen it
um at the weekend so maybe just before
the weekend uh Patrick Harvey one of the
two leaders of the Scottish greens uh
attacked the very idea of vaccine
passports uh and what have we seen well
we've seen the uh Scottish government
yesterday effectively announced the
introduction of vaccine passports and uh
Patrick Harvey and his uh co-government
Minister Lorna Slater the other
co-leader of the greens are the two now
in government they're just going to have
to suck that up and meanwhile the green
party has issued a statement saying
they're very worried about vaccine
passport so it has a lot of problems uh
for them I think there's also a huge
issue you don't want to get two
parochial here but these things matter
in Scotland is the upgrading of the A9
Road that's the road from Perth to
Inverness and the a96 which is the road
from Aberdeen to Inverness these are
dangerous roads at the moment they're
not all dual carriageway and it is a
very popular policy which the SNP have
supported to fully duel to make them
fully dual Carriage Way roads make them
safer make them easier to drive on it's
not clear that the greens want to go
along with that indeed I'm pretty sure
they don't want to go along with it so
there's a plenty of opportunity I think
for some grit in the Oyster here
um but as you say it's all about
independence with Nicholas sturgeon's
got a disconference coming up in the
Autumn can you give us a look ahead to
what that independence reigniting of
that debate will look like because she's
being relatively quiet in recent months
because of kovid I guess uh in pushing
that cause
the line has been Cindy they don't want
to push and Depends or a second
referendum which is an essential first
stage towards the possibility of
Independence until they've got on top of
covert now that's a problem for them
because we learned yesterday from the
world World Health Organization that 50
of the top 20 covered hot spots in the
world are now in Europe and now in
Scotland 50 so not quite clear that
they're actually getting on top of
covert but nevertheless she has her
party activists uh that she has to feed
this red meat to there's not a lot else
she has to talk about if you look at the
record on education or in schools or
health or crime now where there's a
problems with the latest crime figures
in Scotland or even in infrastructure I
mean other than the new bread over new
bridge over the fourth there's not a lot
of major infrastructure the main road
between Glasgow and Edinburgh which is
the main archery in central Scotland
there's still there's something there's
now about 50 years out of date there's
no high-speed Railways in Scotland
there's no Titanic infrastructure other
than the bridge which closes in bad
weather by the way too so you wouldn't
want to make that too to temic so she's
not got a lot of red meat to snowball
that matters for them is Independence
this with alliance with the greens helps
her get through that she also thinks
it's now a stronger argument with Boris
Johnson she can say look I've got a
super majority in the Hollywood uh uh
Parliament I've got 72 out of 129 votes
when I add in the greens for
Independence or for a second referendum
so you can't deny that to me but I think
Mr Johnson will uh and I think he'll say
look until there's a a clear indication
that the Scots want a second referendum
and there isn't yet uh very only I think
about 35 percent wanted on Nicholas
sturgeon's timetable I think he'll just
say no and there was a significant
development from the Scottish Secretary
of State in the past days where he
actually firmed up on what the yardstick
would be
for a second referendum which was that
the Paul's furry prolonged period of
time need to show 60 or more of Scots
want a second referendum now they're
nowhere near that at the moment he got
criticized for saying that but actually
I think it was a shrewd move because of
the Westminster government does not give
some kind of criteria as to what would
trigger a second referendum then
Nicholas sturgeon could rightly argue
that there was no Democratic route to
Independence that there was no the
Westminster government you could just
say no no no no now you can argue
whether 60 is high enough or too high
that's one thing but they've set a
yardstick no which means that there is a
democratic route to a second
Independence referendum if it is the
clear and user favorite phrase of the
Scottish nationalist the settled will of
the Scottish people that they want a
second referendum
very interesting Andrew and while I've
got you here I know that you've been
following the situation in Afghanistan
very closely
um in all of your years of doing
journalism how big of a moment do you
think that the last month that we've
seen will be considered by history books
oh I think this is a watershed moment I
think it's huge it come back you know
it's been compared to previous historic
events uh in modern times but actually I
think it it combines uh or all of them
it it combines The Retreat from Saigon
in 1975 uh out to the retreat from
Saigon was done in a rather more
measured way despite that helicopter
famous helicopter picture coming off the
U.S embassy uh there was a much more
measured Retreat because the Saigon
government lasted for two years after
the Americans had effectively withdrawn
it didn't all just happen overnight
despite that uh determining picture so I
think this has been big as that it has
elements of farce and embarrassment of
the Bay of Pigs invasion when the CIA
sponsored a cube anti-communist Cuban
rebellion in Invasion which ended in
farce and total Victory uh for Fidel
Castro secured his position and Power in
fact and of course the hostage situation
in Tehran in 1980 and we know that there
are still a number of American citizens
not just allies of America a number of
American citizens who are still in
Afghanistan including 32 students from
California now there is Mr Biden's next
Crisis staring him in the face how does
he get these kids out what were they
doing there in the first place is
another matter but how does he get them
out so I think if you look at this uh it
has all the elements of the Bay of Pigs
Saigon and the Tehran hostage crisis
rolled into one and out of that
humiliation an embarrassment
and the the denigration of American
power and American standing on the world
comes major geopolitical changes which
can only strengthen the position
of China in places like Pakistan as well
as Afghanistan and of Russia in the
Central Asian stands the the the the
stands that used to be Soviet parts of
the Soviet Empire and you can even see
an emboding of Iran with Russian and
Chinese support in the Middle East as
well so I think the geopolitical
ramifications of this embarrassment and
humiliation have yet to unfold and I see
that Mr Biden has said I was just
looking that he said that the war was
now over the Afghan war was now over
that's its exact praise the war in
Afghanistan is now over well the
jihadists don't believe that I think
Isis care the akani network Al-Qaeda
will all be pouring in there again to
use it as a base the jihadist certainly
don't believe that and I fear that far
from being over is simply the next phase
of the war not being over and a more
dangerous phase
engineer thank you so much for joining
us on the show
now if you're enjoying the show we think
that you'd also enjoy The Spectator
Magazine with all its online print and
archive content you can access all that
we offer and have a free bottle of pins
when you subscribe at spectator.co.uk
forward slash TV offer
now it's been a summer of animal stories
from Geronimo the alpaca to Penn
farthing's dogs and cats it's often said
that Britain is a nation of animal
lovers but has the last few months shown
that we've actually taken this to the
extreme two in five Brits now say that
animal lives are worth just as much as
human lives Wilmore The Spectators
features editor read rails against this
moral reprioritization in this week's
spectator cover article and he joins
spectator TV today together with the
animal rights campaigner Dominic Dyer
who has been on the Forefront of these
Animal Welfare stories
now will you write that these are signs
of moral collapse how say
the point I make about moral collapse is
it's it comes when uh you put animal
life at the expense of human life that's
where it's a problem there is of course
nothing wrong with loving animals
um I think the reason politicians always
say We're a nation of animal lovers is
because it is true and it is so
obviously true and that's a very good
thing but uh love can uh go wrong you
can love
um like Othello uh not wisely but too
well and and it's when it's when love uh
for Animals gets into the territory
where where you sort of just caring for
them and having high standards of Animal
Welfare which is a very good thing that
um you start to treat animals as if they
have rights as akin to Human Rights and
that is where I think it gets very
worrying and that's where I think I I do
think it it it's a sign of moral
collapse because we're in a you get to a
stage whereby there's a lot of people in
this country who a much more concerned
with uh you know with with animals and
dogs and cats and so on than they are
with uh you know uh how the Taliban
treat women for example because they
that's what they have that's what they
are passionate about so it's a point
really about um public perception uh I
think more than anything
well that was that incredible yoga of
couple that came out recently that said
actually two-fifths of people in the UK
actually think that animals lives are
worth as much as human lives well yes
exactly I mean so then that's yes that's
a poll from last week and uh that is a
point about public perception of events
um you know I'm sure Dominic and I are
about to talk about operation Arc uh but
my my point really is it's it's it's
bigger than operation Arc itself it's
how the public responded to it that's
what I'm really was interested in with
the piece it's it's a it's a shift in
public attitude uh and it's a shift that
I think takes one dangerous step too far
it it takes this well-meaning uh
instinct which is to love nature to care
for nature uh and it but it push pushes
it into the territory where by elevating
animals
um and by humanizing them it actually
has an effect where
um uh people are dehumanized and that's
really what I was trying to get at with
the piece yeah and Dominic do you see
this love going into something a bit
more sinister
oh you know I've been involved in White
Hall and governments and Industry and
then on to Wildlife and conservation in
my career so you know I've not come this
sort of far from a perspective where I
put animals before people I think there
is a huge caring compassionate movement
for animal welfare and Wildlife
protection in this country and I think
it's a very good thing it makes me proud
to be British there's much that divides
us politically you know brexit and
issues around immigration and the
economy and everything else but actually
you'll find a lot of common ground
between people on the left and right of
the spectrum when it comes to wanting to
protect animals and I see the Animal
Welfare movement as being just as
important in my view as the anti-slavery
movement the universal suffrage movement
the civil rights movement and I think
people who are behind it and many are on
the right behind it this is not a
movement that is necessarily collected
to the left you know I can think of
people at Andrea Jenkins MP I can think
about Trudy Pritchard who's been usually
influential in operation Arc I can you
know Rod little your associate editor
has been helping me a lot on Geronimo
and also an operation Arc in recent
weeks you know this is a movement that
has very strong links in the right wing
of politics in the conservative
supporter base and I think those people
that read your magazine and and
understand many of the issues you're
concerned about are deeply concerned
about animals and and I don't think we
should underestimate that and I think
what we've seen with regards to issues
like Geronimo and and operation Arc is
is a a connection with people you know
people look at Helen McDonald and think
actually I can feel for her in a
relationship with that alpaca I feel for
her fighting with this government
department for five years just to get a
decent test to prove the animal doesn't
have TB and they were absolutely
horrified the way that defra went onto
that farm with people with hazmat suits
on like they come out of a nuclear
reactor and actually drag the animal
away there's no one would say that was
something that should happen in a
civilized society and when it came to
pen and operation Arc remember that was
a humanitarian Mission you know it
started with me because I sit on the
board of the Royal College of Veteran
Resurgence Veterinary nurses Council I
was very concerned about the veterinary
nurses about their you know young women
that have been trained given the
opportunities to do Veterinary nurse and
Veterinary work because of money that
was raised from Britain and America you
know our soldiers died over 450 in that
war or they invested that with their
blood in their lives to give a
generation the opportunity to be
empowered not least women and that's
where that started and that's why it got
so much hold and that's why the Royal
College of Veteran Resurgence of British
Veterinary Association big business like
Vets for Pets all got behind it wrote to
the Prime Minister and it was that that
started it the animals were just part of
the picture we wanted to rescue the
animal rescuers and if we could bring
the animals with us as well then that
was something that would be good and
they'd all come off that plane I don't
think there would have been any disputes
about how wonderful that was out of this
terrible sad Saga that was going on in
Afghanistan so I think yes we have hit a
court I think this summer has shown how
people care but I think it's not just
unique to Britain you know if you look
at what's been going on in the US in the
last few days there's a huge outcry now
about dogs being left on the runway at
Kabul Airport the Department of Defense
took military dogs but it didn't take
contract to dogs and they're left
wandering around and that media are all
looking at them and it's going all the
way up to the White House and Fox News
and a lot of commentators on the
conservative side of the debate in
America are really pushing this debate
to say that should never have happened
if we'd have left the dogs that pen had
on that Runway you'd have had a similar
debate here in Britain people would have
been going very angry indeed and one
final point I suppose and I don't agree
with this but a lot of people that
subscribe to your magazine are on the
right of politics probably would rather
have dogs coming in than people I don't
believe in that you know I'm a Believer
in bringing people into this country's
refugees and settling them because I
think we have to do that but there is a
view maybe that animals go before people
in some people's minds it's not
something I share I think if we're if
we're good to animals we're generally
good for people and I think that's a
strong point in British Society we
should be very proud of that I mean I'm
very glad you you uh you you don't think
that uh we should put animals before
before people but I was struck in just
then
um Dominic when you when you did compare
the pet Liberation movement to slavery
um which I just find a very interesting
comparison because I do make the point
in the piece that this these comparisons
between wanting to uh to help animals
but comparing to these you know terrible
uh uh things that people in history had
had to suffer through
um I do think that has a dehumanizing
effect on people even if that's not the
intention I think that that is what
happens I mean in my piece I mentioned
uh Peter that the animal rights
organization
um the largest animal rights
organization in the world uh and their
2003 Holocaust on your plate campaign
where they they juxtaposed images of uh
battery hens alongside a concentration
camp inmates and with with the words
two chickens or to hens perhaps I can't
remember no two animals I think to
animals all people are Nazis uh and that
to me seems so blatantly wrong even if
that comes again from a good place of
wanting to to look after animals and
treat them well
um when you're getting to that sort of
stage where where you're dehumanizing
people in that way
um supposedly at the benefit for Animals
I I do think that's that's that's nasty
and and I would also say that the
um yes you say that that you don't
believe in prioritizing animals ahead of
people but I think what the whole Saga I
suppose um around operation Arc showed
to me is that there are a lot of people
in the general public who disagree with
that which I find quite dismaying I'm
glad we both share the opinion that it
is a dismaying thing but that we I I
also mentioned in the piece this cool
made to LBC by a member of the public
who you know when asked if it really was
a choice between getting someone on the
plane as who's not an interpreter and
getting a dog on a plane you're saying
put the dog on uh and she said yes uh
and you could say you know the system
the one member of the public
um you know doesn't represent wider
beliefs however there is that uh yougov
poll uh putting uh at 40 now of the
public claim that they see animal lives
as equal to uh in worth human lives so
there is it I think it is a growing
Trend it is still a minority Trend but
it is a growing one and I think that
once you've once you've crossed that
line from the very admirable causes of
animal welfare and then but into the
into the territory where you want
animals to have rights as akin to Human
Rights that's I think very worrying
yeah you know we'll just sort of address
a few of those points you know I don't
agree with the comparisons between the
Holocaust having a partner who lost
relatives in the Holocaust unit having
met many Holocaust Survivors and studied
that period of History very well I'm not
going to accept that we should be making
those comparisons so I don't agree with
what Peter does in that area
um even though I know some Holocaust
Survivors have made those comparisons so
yeah they've got a right to do so if
they choose yes bearing in mind what
they've been through
um but if we look at the issue of
slavery for example and we look at the
unit the universal suffrage and civil
rights this was trying to improve the
rights of people and and and to move
Society forward and I think what I'm
trying to say is that actually animal
welfare and animal rights is moving
Society forward you know there's Real
Horror for example that we spend so much
time trying to improve the situation
with dogs and I work with many
conservative MPS and ministers most
recently on trying to ensure that we get
mandatory checks on microchips before
dogs are euthanized we've had huge
support from the government on that and
I'm really grateful for it but it
strikes me that if we're taking so much
action to protect dogs that we have as
companion animals we still allow dogs to
be bred by American companies like with
this firming in in Huntington MBR
resources that actually breeds over 20
000 dogs in a facility in New York and
over 2 000 here to go into chemical
tests and I've worked in the industries
where these tests are undertaken they're
outdated they're outmoded mostly for
pesticides and household chemicals and
it's absolutely horrendous and quite
rightly now that uh you know pretty
patella's Home Secretary is being put
under pressure to look at why we have
regular Traditions like that that Force
the use of those types of animals it's
the same with using primates and animal
experiments I want to see that end I
think most civilized people would want
to see that end I think most civilized
people would want to see dog experiments
end and I think we should be moving in
that direction we should be prouder we
can bring that about I think in relation
to operation Arc as I said you know to
me the only reason we got so much
traction with operation art was because
the dogs were part of the story
otherwise that group of Afghans would
just be another group of people that
were faceless and you know their emails
never even open in the foreign office
with hundreds of names but what we're
able to do is we're able to put faces
and their work with animals together and
really it was the animals that would
have got the people at home if you
understand the logic of what we were
doing the animals would have got safe
passages from of the people and to me
that was the story because they cared
for the animals they were the animal
rescuers would rescue them too and
that's what we were trying to do so
we're making a direct connection we
weren't saying pets before people that
was something that Mr Wallace and his
political advisors in mod came out with
because they were trying to delay the
operation I think they got egg over
their face because other parts of
government from Downing street down the
foreign office and home office could see
what we were trying to do and even defra
and I have my differences massively with
them on the killing of of Geronimo the
alpaca were really helpful on all
aspects of getting those animals safely
into the UK and into into quarantine
candles where they are so this idea that
you know we're trying to push an agenda
that's putting people second in animals
first I don't think that's the case what
we're trying to say is we move Society
forward we improve the rights of animals
we improve the rights of people you know
there's a lot of evidence to show you
that when people are violent towards
animals you know if you want to go back
to the Moors murders and you see what
you know that was going on at that time
where cats and dogs were being killed
before they turned on children you can
see there's lots of evidence that people
that are Psychopathic towards animals
and and kill them will take that anger
out on people as well so you know
compassion towards animals is something
we should welcome in our society it's a
good thing it means that we have less
violence towards people as well it makes
us a better society and I think Britain
can be proud of the fact that
organizations like WWF started here
rspca compassion in World farming the
Born Free foundation and I work with the
Virginia McKenna is 90 that's incredible
and still does amazing work in this area
all of these people have put Britain on
the map for being the center of of an
Animal Welfare movement and to be fair
to the government they are trying to
capture that too with that Animal
Welfare strategy you know with people
working in government for Zach Goldsmith
we've carried Johnson in Downing Street
with Stanley Johnson and all the people
that talk out on these things I do think
it's a good thing it's not something to
be negative about there are huge
challenges there'll always be debates
about where people come into this and
where animals come into it but equally I
think any politician that underestimates
the power of this growing Force as
Teresa made it in 2019 on the hunting
Act and the ivory act she paid a heavy
price politically for that and partly
lost a majority because of it Boris
Johnson I think didn't make the same
mistake in 2020 election sorry 2017 I'm
talking about Theresa May but in 2019
Boris Johnson didn't make the same
mistake but at the end of the day you
know all of us realize now this is a
growing force in politics and I'm happy
to be part of that yes it definitely is
a growing force in politics I mean I I
made that point in in the piece I I
think you're completely right about that
but I don't think that necessarily means
that the the public shift in how they
perceive animals is right even if it is
popular I mean you said there that that
um the reason that people you know got
to invested in operation Arc was the uh
because the animals were involved with
it and I think you're completely right
and I also think that's very dismaying I
mean I thought the most telling bit of
the whole thing was the um when Penn
Farthing obviously under a lot of stress
sent that voicemail message that was
leaked to the government Aid and I
thought the telling part about that was
when he said that he would um foreign
he could turn the country against him uh
through social media and I think he's
right you know I think I think he didn't
he didn't even need to to to give that
uh sort of order of um attack because
there were already people who were a
passionate passionate enough about the
issue and worked up enough about it to
be doing uh that already and to be uh
harassing people involved in the
evacuation of Kabul and I I do find that
pretty dismaying
um and then on the point you made a
point about primates and experimentation
um
and there was a very good point made by
baroness Dietz when talking about
um criticisms of the animal sentience
bill and I think it was a good point
which was that our covid-19 vaccines
um they came into fruition because of
early experimentation on mice and
ferrets and primates and a primate is
obviously and it's a beautiful animal
it's very
um Advanced uh animal in terms of
sentience
um but that was an example that you know
if we didn't have those vaccines now
it's estimated that as many as a hundred
thousand more lives could have been lost
in this country to covid would probably
all still be in lockdown which has
greater costs on on society in them on
people's lives and and their rights as
as as humans to to to you know leave
their own homes
um and so that was an example where
if if that if the primates had had
rights that meant On a par with human
rights that it meant that they had
couldn't have uh these covered
experimentation on them you know there's
we would not have had these vaccines or
at least not had them as fast as we had
them uh in this sort of Race Against
Time against the virus so that's a sort
of another example in my mind of where
um you know you the animal welfare in my
mind is best when it is trying to
minimize unnecessary suffering to
animals I mean the abhorrence of Cruelty
I think is a it's a wonderful trait to
have to abhor cruelty
but there are examples difficult
examples I think where where suffering
is necessary with animals
um in order that human lives and human
dignity
um can be helped and that's just to come
back on unfortunately but that is the
experiment of the situation I think
yeah just come back on the
experimentation issue because it's
important you make a fair point you know
primates we use a small number of
primates in an American University for
the uh
um the AstraZeneca Oxford University
vaccine process
um it wasn't the case for the Pfizer
side of things
um but the one thing we learn actually
with regards to what happened with those
vaccines is they moved human trials
really quickly the level of animal
expectation experimentation in relation
to those covid vaccines has been tiny
compared with other
non-pharmaceutical based you know
regulatory systems including for
household chemicals and pesticides and
other things and it shows actually when
the pressure is on and when government
Regulators allow this to move to human
trials quickly we can get these
medicines to the market and we can get
them into people's arms in this case and
save you know millions of lives I think
the problem is not with the use of
animals it's with the regulatory system
that forces the use of animals I think
if you speak to most large companies I
used to work in the agrochemical
industry and I used to have this debate
all the time the companies I work with
did not want to use animals and
experiments but they were forced to use
them because of the regulatory system
that was in place case and often they
would have disputes with the U.S
Regulators or european Regulators about
the need to do it so I think you know it
isn't a necessary evil that we have to
kill animals to do all these experiments
I think that the covid-19 trials and the
rapid move to get those vaccines into
people which has been miraculous and I'm
hugely grateful to everyone involved as
you are we all should be
um has shown that actually the the level
of an animal experimentation needed is
is much smaller than it has been in the
past in those processes and actually we
can get to to trial much more quickly
with human trials I think it's extremely
good that it is lessening I mean that is
an excellent we can get there I think
the government are committed to that and
I think we will get there so I think it
is a step in the right direction but
just to come back on on the pen firing
issue because I want to clarify that the
phone call because you know Mr Quentin
and the aid I spoke to Mr Quentin an
hour before Penn made that phone call
and I tore a strip off Mr Quentin
without any expletives because I was
well aware of what he was doing in
Whitewater delay getting a flight
authorization working with under the
direction of Mr Wallace and I said to
him we're having real problems here you
know unless we can get the authorization
via the ministry of Defense to get into
that airport we're not going to be able
to get a a contractor to fly in and the
number of aircraft that we have
available diminishing by the hour we
have the money to do this and I was
going from operators in Istanbul to
operators in Eastern Europe to operators
in in the United Arab Emirates and Cairo
and all of them were saying listen
you've not got us a flight number we
can't get you the plane and you can't
get you the plane it's not going to
happen so Quentin was in the firing line
he got the criticism he deserved he was
muddying the waters with ministers I've
made it very clear in a number of
interviews uh what happened with Penn
was he was exasperated he was at the end
of his tether uh his people were under
direct risk he was under at risk yes he
was under pressure so he left a very
expletive written message I think most
people in that situation would have
probably done the same quite frankly and
I think actually the release of that the
release of that tape to the Sunday Times
which had a long discussion with them
before they published it in my view was
fundamentally wrong and I've debated
with Mr Wallace and I'll continue to
about what he did on that issue can I
cut can I cut him here because we're
running out of time and fascinating
discussion we're having here but I just
entity
um to respond to William Will's point
about social media and the fact that the
content of that voicemail was penfolding
knowing very well what he could unleash
do you not think that I mean I know that
you're a keen user of Twitter yourself
do you not think that a lot of this is
whipping up mob mentality in In a
Sentimental way you know there's so many
animals who get put down because of TB
or you know so many animals that will
suffer in war zones but you know it's
social media that's really making it can
I explain to you what what would you
have done in my situation okay we'd
worked all week you know the Prime
Minister had approved the visas for the
for people to leave the 68 through
pretty Patel okay we had the whole of
defra working on getting the animals in
okay I had the money on the table from a
wealthy American investor in the United
States Spencer Haber to get the plane
that we needed to get on the airport I'd
worked on it for 10 days and I had a
political Aid suddenly in the shadows in
in Whitehall in the Minister of Defense
basically telling ministers to back off
Corsa was angry you know what I do yeah
can I just explain what we did I took to
social media okay and I made a direct
appeal to the prime minister to say
intervene after the G7 Summit I made a
little video on my phone I got over 350
000 shares on it went straight to dine
Street all the people sharing because
yes they got actually bombarded by it
and at 1 50 in the morning Mr Wallace
clearly under huge pressure from the
Prime Minister put out a tweet saying he
changed his policy 360 Degrees we could
take the animals in we could take the
people in and we could get the plane
okay then I went on Good Morning Britain
and I basically said that you know this
is a really difficult time we need to
get that plane on the ground as soon as
possible I was in tears millions of
people watching it and then Wallace
blunders in and starts to abuse me and
say that basically I was talking
nonsense I was abusing troops he was
Slaughter Charlotte Hawkins basically
pulled him up saying what are you doing
he'd been on the television and radio
the day before saying we were talking
bollocks he was making himself look
stupid he was making Downing Street
extremely uncomfortable he was trying to
undermine a policy that the whole
government had lined up to support and
ultimately ultimately he was endangering
lies because we couldn't get those
people through the gate and in the end
we didn't I hold him responsible for
that I've got to try and get them out as
others out of Afghanistan that's a
bloody difficult thing and Dominic Rabb
flying to Pakistan today and we've got
hundreds of other people that are in a
very dangerous situation I won't forgive
him for that he didn't need to delay
that flight the minute that he made that
tweet the minute the Downing Street
forced him to change I had the air
Commodore ringing me directly in the
morning via his office to say Dominic
you can have all the flight
authorization details you need just
passes on to your operators which I did
and we got it all sorted that could have
been sorted days before so that's why
that phone call was made from penfabbing
that's why I ripped a strip off Peter
Quentin that's why I went to war with
Ben Wallace in the media and that's why
ultimately he lost Dominic Dyer Wilmore
we'll have to leave it there but thank
you for joining spectator TV and last
our boarding schools emotionally
stunting boys who then grow up to ruin
the country through politics that's the
argument that the author Richard beard
makes in a new book sad little men
reviewed in the latest issue of The
Spectator by Nicholas lizard Richard is
a product of boarding school himself and
writes that he recognizes much of the
traits in prime ministers like David
Cameron and Boris Johnson from his
boarding school life
Richard beard welcome to Space Age TV
first what led you to writing this book
uh well we're in the start of the first
lockdown and I was seeing uh the way
that we were being led by our by our
government by um
uh prime minister Johnson in particular
and I was thinking how I recognized many
of his behaviors and they seemed to be
traceable back to
um to his education which
um I share although in different schools
the same form of education and I
suddenly felt it was very important to
bring these news back to everybody else
who hadn't experienced it so that the
links could be seen between
um a lot of these kind of texts and
habits which we start to take for
granted but I think do have their Source
very clearly in early life what sort of
text are we talking about here yeah
well I think the um I mean in the book
inside little men I go through the uh
various things that can be traced I
think an obvious one is the joking the
fact that that everything must be seen
to be a bit of a laugh as a way of
disarming it really so if nothing's
important nothing can can hurt you and
it's a form of self-defense which is
used
um in boarding schools in particular
um and uh it can be then extended out
into life so that anything which seems
tricky or anything which makes you feel
vulnerable can just be made into a joke
um and uh and I think that's one form of
behavior which which clearly uh runs
very deep
um in many of our Public School
politicians
so I mean self-defense is not a nation
one usually assumes uh that comes with
school was boarding school particularly
or is boarding school a particularly
traumatic experience
well I think self-defense is an
essential art to learn probably in all
schools but um in an exaggerated way in
a boarding school because you have no
one else to to do that defense for you
uh you are left there on your own
um among other boys all of whom are
trying to to hide their own sadness and
hide their own vulnerabilities and the
best form of Defense ultimately become
becomes a tag or it becomes this kind of
wall of uh
um against emotions of any kind because
if by showing emotions you can become
very very vulnerable and therefore I
think self-defense is very important in
these schools and it's one of the first
things you learn you learn for example
not to show that you're sad and homesick
as your parents drive away that becomes
a very important lesson which then can
be applied to all sorts of other
situations you know if in doubt just
close down put up a wall
I mean has it been cathartic for you to
write this book because I know that you
write that you've now moved back to your
close to your boarding school so is
there some kind of complex psychology
going on there
well I think there was but it was before
I wrote the book I I as I was here in
lockdown and I found that I'm living
half a mile
um from the school I went to which is
Radley College in Oxfordshire and I
suddenly thought well this isn't so
innocent but I mean true to my own type
my own character type
um I hadn't bothered to look into that
very deeply until we all had nothing to
do and I was allowed out you know once a
day for an hour so it seemed an obvious
place to go and to go and kind of
rummage around both now in the present
and and in terms of the past the book is
very much about the past of these
schools I went to boarding school in
1975 which was the same year as David
Cameron and Boris Johnson and I feel
sort of very
um
ready to talk about that period but not
necessarily about the schools as they
are now but about that period I do feel
that I'm an expert and I've read up on
lots of experts from the psychological
field as well it's kind of a growing
field
um and they very much say that there are
issues here which need to be need to be
addressed and I hope to popularize some
of their more academic arguments in the
book as well what about it was
particularly traumatizing because is it
just the separation from your parents
and not seeing them for weeks on end or
is there something else you know you
often hear about public school culture
and bullying that sort of stuff is there
anything that that's that inherent in
these schools at least of that period
and that made it particularly
traumatizing
well I think that the separation is the
main thing but I do want to say that you
know I personally
um was not bullied I personally didn't
have a particularly terrible time in
many ways I had the best time possible
because I was very good at sport
um I saw at the top of the class
um and uh so therefore I had that kind
of status of a the Schoolboy seek again
in a kind of defensive way so it's not
really about these specific traumas
about bullying I mean there are other
books which um are about
um the pedophilia which um was present
in these schools in the 70s that's not
something that I have experienced
um and my point really is that I had a
kind of normal or a standard to good
time
um in in my public school and yet still
that basic trauma of
separation from the family and then the
social consequences of being segregated
from wider Society
the psychosexual consequences of being
separated from girls and women
um and from from again from from from uh
what would be considered a normal
community life all those things will
affect boys who went to these schools at
that time whether they like it or not
whether they were successes or not
whether they were the bullies or the
bullied
um and it doesn't really matter what
your specific if you were specifically
traumatized by individual events it's
it's the it's the fact of having gone
there we'll have these long-term
consequences
um I think whatever the experience
well Richard can I push back a bit here
because you mentioned Boris Johnson you
mentioned David Cameron and
understandably a lot of people you know
don't like them or the way that they do
things but boarding school has also
given us people like where she see anak
who are a little bit more balanced less
about joking around more about perhaps
working hard and more you've it's also
given us Churchill Orwell John le Carrie
the list goes on so are you being a bit
unfair here
well of the of the of the people you
mentioned that of the Churchill
um famously didn't like his his schools
and didn't want to claim any of his sort
of character coming from them and John
Carey very much outspoken against
um against public schooling and uh his
experience as a teacher at Eaton
um and um I think that that's uh that's
quite revealing in itself
um I'm not quite sure what you'll
pushback kind of is is say that there
are different type of people who come
out of the schools that's clearly true
um and again I would say I'm looking at
the specific period I think Rishi sunak
is a bit younger I think uh children in
these schools now will exhibit different
behaviors later on I do think there are
some things which haven't changed which
are still problematic in this
segregation from uh The Wider Community
is one of those problems which we'll
have
um an impact and will have consequences
later I mean clearly people can react in
different ways and there are people who
go on to live amazingly useful
um lives um have altruistic careers
are wonderful people
um but they do that often in spite of
their education because of course one of
the consequences is that you can then
compensate and even overcompensate to
try and
um sort of make up for that lost time
um so I'm not not I would never say that
you know that's kind of one size fits
all in the consequences it can go
exactly the other other way but it is in
spite of that education and it's
interesting then that the school will
often try and claim that success for
themselves and I do know anecdotally of
well-known individuals in humanitarian
Fields who really try very hard not to
let the schools do that
and Richard finally
um you say that your experience is
pegged to the 1970s and that now it
might be different I mean boarding
school certainly today are probably a
bit more pampered at least certainly
more International in their cohort so do
you think that your the things that you
find in your book apply to the later
generations of people who go to boarding
a school or are an argument against the
institution of boarding schools today
well I think that's the kind of thing
which we're going to find out in 30
years time when if Society doesn't
change
um heaven forbid that the same kind of
people will be in charge people go to
the same schools will be in charge uh
certainly this is something which came
back in the in in when when Cameron
became
um promised in 2010 I think a lot of
people thought this would never happen
again the big Public Schools wouldn't be
providing our leadership but if they're
still doing so in 30 years time then
whatever those children are experiencing
now
um the boys and girls as they are now
who'll become the men and women who are
in charge we will then see what the
consequences are and it's a bit too late
probably if things
um are as problematic as they are at the
moment
Richard bid thanks for joining spectator
TV and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed this episode don't forget to
subscribe to The Spectators YouTube
channel so you never miss an episode
just click the Subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and the bell icon
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]